hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to destiny rebellion
okay I'm not gonna be screaming in joy
nearly as much as I have in the past
because my voice is kind of getting a
little bit of a workout but that's okay
I'll make it up with crazy facial
expressions oh look how amazing this
look how amazing this is I can't believe
how fantastical this level design is I
am so enthused right now and I'm
assuming that is death right there oh
you deft me how dare you or I'm so angry
at you oh no I just again sorry this is
not working out
all right back to normal okay I'm
assuming I can climb that yes I can God
look at this I can't believe I'm still
playing amnesia oh okay so I thought I
was going to do a sick flip wall jump
off into the abyss oh what's that you
want me to keep making [ __ ] hi pie pie
pie pie
oh god damn it
okay I can't do that either cuz
apparently I'm gonna wreck my face just
my whole bottom jaw is gonna rip off out
of a look two tequilas are than anyway
god I have to say this is absolutely
astonishing like he took the world of
amnesia and made it his own that is
really cool and that is the sign of like
a really imaginative game developer he
made something completely unique that no
one would think of made who would look
at the amnesia toolset and make
something like this I don't even care if
this is like just all placeholder stuff
any like meant to do something the
stylistic choice of it and the way it
makes me think of portal is really cool
I love this I love everything about this
this is cool look at that that's a piece
of
floating around God that is ridiculous
I'm not Lazar I don't have the clutter
can't give me this time I am too good
for you god this whole claustrophobia
level that is absolutely amazing chapter
five finished
claustrophobia is serious fear it is
abnormal and uncontrollable fear of
being in small clothes and narrow places
often connected to elevators well he's
gonna be sorely disappointed in the
future because if humanity doesn't die
here that's gonna be oh are you okay you
got some crazy seizures in the elevator
we are viewer legit boilerplate and fine
tiny box Tim otherwise known as him the
final showdown between me and tiny box
Tim I just like I like getting close
tonight it's awfully fancy for me
truth is devastating isn't it don't
worry everything was foretold and you
cannot change simple thing the sooner
you expected the less painful it is are
you talking about my wife are you
talking about my wife cuz how dare he
first of all how dare you talk about my
wife like that I am trying to get this
as second of all also how dare you cuz
you are son of [ __ ] cuz you know what
shove your fate and time up your own ass
and suck on that because also you're a
dick and I'm not very good at insulting
so I'm just gonna move on ok I can't
read that I can't read that either let's
just move forward
okay okay those dollars a chump you're
no threat for me anymore
shovel ski I command thee to die because
I'm kind of mean like that okay so
suddenly I gain the power to destroy
every monster in existence because
that's cool and all and totally within
the realm of possibility and now oh okay
okay I don't understand the brothers
were not good enough for what I can't
stop laughing y'all so naked for me
intelligent enough to become very place
you is you you're not very smart
because you're any sense I have created
I machine
I know I know I know a listen there is
no way to save your wife yes you will
never try so hard study behind the build
time machine okay so that's cool and all
with grease and many people did
everything so I could become your
successor you dick how dare you third of
all how dare you fight wait oh oh not to
fight well first of all you're a dick
second of all I don't think this
ultimate power thing would ever work out
so he all right neck dude is bring it on
I'm gonna I'm gonna beat you in your
face
I'm going to destroy you with my fists
apparently oh oh bring it on a pretty
big guy I'll bring it out old man I'm
gonna show wait oh man wait a minute I
gotta get I gotta get me yeah sorry it's
a long run I'm gonna scream when I get
there I think
a marital yeah gave me mortal how that
hurt by yo how you bet got you haha
you're gonna succumb to something if you
know what I mean no I don't think so am
i being hit right now okay level
transition apparently I'm gonna get you
out with my sward and my super-awesome
skills maybe okay no world would end
universe exploded see if you change the
past your present but I'll be with my
wife right but only your bath without
precious knowledge will stay it would be
like nothing happened in the last 70
years okay
oh I'm still fine no I got that I need
this
I'm gonna getcha wow you're so scary
right through the face let's do the face
you douche oh come on bring it on
whoo this is cool actually Wow hockey
saggy
oh come at me bro all right oh wow that
is a big-ass ward well yeah oh hell yeah
you're bringing on you douche bring it
on [ __ ] how do I have name of that hang
on I need to hold this correctly it's
kind of big and unwieldy barrel bear
with me for say haha stab you in the
dick did I get you y'all old wrinkly
bastard all right cool oh my god
is that a purple what hole my goodness
what is going on here I like that okay
okay I'm gonna beat him but apparently
you can fall in pits and die that is
apparently a thing even though it wasn't
a thing over here so I got a walk on the
white and this does Silman hey super
sward you
Oh what this heart here this part of the
universe thing the thing that seems very
very important yay all right whoa what
is wrong with my leg what is wrong with
my face aha RPG now heavy attack hell
yeah
bring it on you douche I'm just gonna go
all all heavy attacks because apparently
I'm gonna heal and then I'm gonna heavy
attack yet again cuz I only know heavy
attacks how we go tyranny is over I'm
gonna light attack just for a little bit
oh my god that was some light attack
goodness I didn't know my light attack
involved about thirteen thousand swords
your day is over now oh oh you did it
oh dude over now now when the master of
time is gone somebody must take his
place there's no other way now when the
master of time has gotten somebody must
take his place there's no other way but
why after all do I have to do this
now you do will return to 1902 and
change our past don't worry I will
handle this system this is the purpose
that I wanted and I will raise up an
environment for months to cut no
humidity you but how you don't possibly
understand the principles of this I do
when you fought I had enough time to
read the manual really Oh what will
happen to you you wanted to meet humans
you wanted to meet humans right I
succeeded I have met you now go don't
worry when we return everything will be
okay when you warn your wife with a
danger you will just forget everything
what happened after that moment okay
good thank you for your help
proceed through the portal the game is
not over yet
all right bye Lazar did I find that I
didn't find the seed of what is that
seed of darkness seed of darkness damn
and I didn't find the seed of darkness I
feel bad about that I I wasn't making a
serious effort to find anything but I
don't know I obviously overlooked it all
right
it was loading for so long I swore that
I was about to end everything okay so um
I'm back in the town I'm gonna go in
here now wait a minute
hello again the last you are here now
you can access all of it if you want to
meet me personally I am in my room just
for you come and feel his home no
jump-scares anymore I promise oh okay
oh I see Oh does that mean there were
jump scares before damn and I should
have gone in here why didn't I go in I
don't know Oh God
oh hi were you the jump scares oh my god
I broke her I broke no it's cool
oh it's cool oh it's cool oh god it's
cool I like it I like it a lot all right
boo-boo-boo-boo-boo-boo-boop anything
else here anything else cool anything
else no that's where it came from
no I'm cool for playing my custom story
congratulations for making it this far
you did a great job of people from my
room and myself well I hope you enjoyed
them out it was great you did a good job
you are awesome I actually really really
access tonight permanently well fine be
that way
dick turn the lights out on you I didn't
but either way uma karna you've made a
fantastic mod I think that it's time to
end this I believe I need to go in my
house I'm not sure but I'm I'm thinking
yes I see a red thing over there I may
need to go that way this is this house
is not my house yet oh okay
well done the game is almost finished
now it's time to check bonus items and
achievement and your Diaries if you want
you can also visit my karma to finish
this story and to Ralph and Christina's
house okay so I didn't go in here before
let me just check real quick what's in
here or not nevermind okay fine I'll go
fine all right I think I got everything
I think pretty sure okay it shows the
good ending okay
okay I didn't do too bad I think I'm not
gonna read through all those but I think
this is where I need to go yep alright
is this good is this the end is it the
end is that you what happened you look
different and my monster is Christie I
would like to tell you so many things
but I just need you to promise me
something oh it's so important for all
these holy to you trust me and promise
me to stay home tomorrow
yeah you cannot go with that train one
morning something terrible is going to
happen you're scaring me how did you
figure that out because travels of time
and space killed the time guide or blew
up the university trusting man there's
no is your safety I just need your
promise and your love what's happening
oh I see I am fading away oh no it means
my mission was
the future is changed for you and my
past self Paul has changed everything
for me
oh thank you so much you're welcome
[Laughter]
after that event the super family lived
long and happy life everything was as if
nothing happened at all oh that's
adorable
Santa said that that guy but still it's
good Ralph did not remember anything
about time machine Lazar or anything
else Lazar the monster became the new
master of time for eternity and at his
side Tim oh that was good that was
really really really really well done I
love that start to finish it was
absolutely wah and I bet I bet that if
you guys want to play this there are a
ton of things that I probably missed in
my rush to finish the game and now I
wasn't even in a rush and I bet that I
missed some barking that's cool oh man
that was absolutely Finn I think I oh hi
hi little girl
how are you doing oh oh god oh god
it may not seem like there's a lot when
you guys are watching this it may seem
unpolished or something like this but
given that I've played a lot of these
custom stories I can understand and
appreciate how much work went into it
especially considering like some custom
stories they they artificially build up
time by making you go back and forth
into certain areas this I never went
back once like I never went back and I
saw so many things throughout this
entire custom story it was phenomenal
one of the best that I played it was
absolutely super duper cool but anyway
I'm gonna stop raving that guys naked
too that guys naked too all right
okay make you guys alright okay yeah I
was going to zyre you have a good one
you have a good one the desire you have
a good one okay yeah right and then
Beethoven and Amadeus Mozart so anyway I
think this is the end of this unless
there's a super special surprise at the
bottom of it if you enjoyed this custom
story please give it a try let me know
in the comments below leave a like for
this series
for getting to the end of it it's
absolutely awesome and if you want to
see even more and these your custom
stories I've listed about five or six of
them five or six are the best ones that
I've ever played in the description so
thank you again everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]